what kind of person like makes hit
pieces on their friends is that is that
a masculine thing to do like people can
you know I I didn't always like fresh
and fit to be honest yeah you guys claim
that don't send that on the guys that's
the thumb guys no at one point I didn't
but like you can you can say what you
want about them but they're they believe
what they say and they would never turn
on their friends it's actually amazing
how loyal they are to their friends
Fresh and fit I'm gonna call them
they're they're so loyal to their
friends you know I wonder I wonder if
they I wonder if these reviews would be
happy if you didn't do podcasting
anymore
they would you reckon yeah no I think
they would I think they like they're
waiting for us to fail that's what they
want that's what they want like that's
why every time our views are lower
they're like oh look she's falling off
or every time like that's why why do you
think these you know these reaction
channels were offering my entire staff
jobs at which none of them took but did
they report on that no and and why is it
is it because they want me to succeed no
they want me to fail in their bullies
all of them are bullies I don't think
you've used listen YouTube for me is
this like a successful Channel goes like
this
if you know stocks you know there's a
downswing an upswing
higher highs and and higher lows
yeah
it goes up and down like this if you
have a channel like certain man it goes
like that
get me
lower highs and lower lows
we're doing higher highs and higher lows
every single YouTube channel no Channel
goes like that and stay go keep going
like that no
even Mr Beast goes like that goes like
that goes like that that's how it works
well it's the long game and that's what
I see you know
um
you know that's I see the long game and
that's what a lot of people think that
like throwing people under the bus in
the short game is good when in the long
game it screws you up because nobody in
the industry wants to work with you and
we see your true character we see your
character and exactly
yeah you burn enough Bridges there'll be
Noble to cross
and it's like do do masculine men make
hit pieces on their friends is that like
something and that's the thing it's like
all these gossip channels they're
they're so feminine it's like they're so
feminine yeah man
do you hear a big man talking about next
big man come on bro
all right who does that bro that's you
that's culture that you try to promote
nah man real man we saw it out in the in
in in in the cigar room
we're chilling in the back no one hears
about it even know that there's there's
disagreements just come boom this is how
we in front with united front in the
back we could argue however but they
don't know about it that's how real men
do it
that's how real women do it and you know
I actually I actually changed my mind on
the whole album preach thing I was team
Abba and preach I was in the beginning
of um the fresh and fit drama but what I
but no I was but I didn't realize how
they took Myron out of context and they
painted him has that like they basically
metooed Myron by painting him as like
some Harvey Weinstein type by not
putting those texts in context it was
actually disgusting I'll tell you what
happened
a comedian
was on
comedically and they couldn't take it
they couldn't take it they couldn't take
man talking about his fat wife they
couldn't take it
sorry but they started it that's
something can I say overweight
what I need to find a cute way of saying
fat whales must look cute okay right
that's if you want to disrespect them I
just want to be like fluffy about it
what's nice and fat
chunky
that's a little over chunky
giving face about they match her again
one giving negative energy in life is a
colossal waste of time learn eventually
I don't want to smoke I'm not coming for
no one that's not in no YouTube space
that's your boo that's you I am not
coming for you whoever I'm saying people
love who they love bro I'm on that
that's the only thing I wish Myron never
went down that road
but
I'm not gonna add homonyms I'll I'll
come I'll come for your belly button and
honestly yeah yeah I gotta get fresh and
fit credit you know I think they offer
you know and this is me even conceding
like they offer more value than anyone
in the space who said more men's
Improvement guys on I can't teach men
game I don't know how to pick up women
I've never done it do you know what I
mean and it's like so they're out here
giving Solutions and making the world a
better place and what like what do these
reaction channels stand for that have
been on them the past year and
a half like I guarantee fresh and fit of
Saved literal lives bro fresh and fit
blue Abba and preach fresh and fit blue
Kevin Samuel fresh and fit blue Andrew
Tate fresh and fit blue jay water fresh
and oh
men after men of the men of the men
Tommy sotomayo's career revived on fresh
and fit I'm telling you the people that
come inside of fresh and fit and have
these amount of people that's watching
them live the real guys that sit down
every day and watch this stuff is
clocking on
yeah you take whatever you want to take
from there they talk about finances
Health Fitness whatever your fed 11
whatever you want to get from that those
two guys you get from over there and I
can even say that I I used to have a
different perspective on them like I
really didn't like them at first but I
can I can genuinely look back and say I
was wrong and triggered back then to be
honest and it's like you don't see all
the good that they're doing but it's
like all Advent preach has done for
years is like hit piece hit piece hit
piece it's like they just sit on the
lives waiting for to take something out
of context so
50 amount of sour breath
how many subscribers I think we've given
wait listen I'm talking way sorry way
too much
you forget why you don't handle
something listen 538 fam
I I think okay I think that Kevin
Samuels also brought a lot of value to
the space I think I think they were both
great in just like different ways
they're all great
yeah
even Destiny Destiny's great at doing
what he's doing he's great these men are
all great I don't on these guys but
if they come for me or come for you I'm
going for them I don't care bro and like
whoever Mr Nice who are the real
grifters the people that don't stand for
anything or believe anything or the
critics like the critics are the real
grifters on YouTube because they follow
where where the trends are where the
people doing General genuine
conversations and pushing the
conversation forward it's like they're
the ones creating the content that
everyone's reacting to I don't listen to
Paul this is how I see it here they say
you stole this dot dot that format from
this one that that or whatever from this
but what I've seen is that
you've used to your tools where everyone
has always done on YouTube yeah and
you've done it better than them and not
only that people like if you check the
timeline correctly you will see that
they took it from you not you took it
from them they took it from you don't
try it Ross I've watched bro sat down
and watched you cats bro what are you
talking about bro do you know how much
YouTube channels cat what we do bro
I'm not and I'm not hating on them
called power to the power to whoever
wants to be a content creator out in
this space is difficult but if you work
hard you get it bro there's enough pies
for everybody